let's bring a bit of breaking news now
this morning uh the chief executive of
Heathrow has announced his resignation
after nine years in charge John Holland
K informed the airport's Board of his
intention to stand down this year and
I'd please say that John Holland Kate
himself joins us now live from Heathrow
very good morning to you thanks so much
for talking to us so why are you
standing down well nine years is a very
long time for any chief executive and
particularly the intense business like
Heathrow which is uh so much so
important to the UK so much in the
public eye but I'm really proud of what
we've achieved in the last nine years
but now that we have come through the
worst of the crisis and I've led the
business through the recovery we've got
a new regulatory period starting uh
anytime now it's a good time for YouTube
executive to come in and transform the
business as much as I hope I have done
over the last nine years well yes and
Heathrow did last year regain its status
as the busiest airport in Western Europe
but it had dropped down the rankings
during the pandemic hadn't it in
retrospect looking back at that time do
you think the government overreacted as
far as travel restrictions were
concerned then
well the UK certainly had tighter travel
restrictions than any other country and
I think it's one of the reasons why UK
Aviation experience a much deeper cut
than happened in many other markets the
Europeans could still fly to each other
the US still had a big domestic market
and of course there was no bailout for
the UK Aviation sector as happened
elsewhere so we really had to dig deep
to survive but I'm really proud of the
way that we have since been able to
recover and just a Heathrow we grew more
in passenger numbers than any other
airport in the world last year that's a
huge achievement and it shows just how
much demand it is for flying and just
how strong heathrow's hub airport model
is in helping to connect all of Britain
to Global growth
should the government have acted
differently though during the pandemic
well that's a question for them but I
think we saw in the pandemic just how
damaging it is to the UK economy to keep
borders closed when you have incidents
like this and I think the borders were
kept close for too long and that had a
really damaging effect not just on
Aviation but on the wider economy and
the reason that matters is because uh
the Heathrow is the biggest Port not
just for people but for goods as well
and 40 of all the UK's non-eu exports go
on passenger planes from Heathrow
they're all they're not flying British
companies can't get their goods to
Market and we're starting to see the
impact of that
reduction in export activity and the
ability to bring supply chain into the
UK right now with the UK economy falling
behind some of our competitors
particularly in Europe
you spent a great deal of your time that
in the job trying to get support for an
expansion of Heathrow to get a third
Runway that ticket approval in 2018 but
it was delayed because of covid so
what's the situation now is that going
to happen and if so when
yes it will happen and we'll be
announcing our plans for how we're going
to do that later in the year and covert
has shown just how important it is that
it does happen and we're now an
independent country we can't rely on our
competitors in Europe to get our Goods
to Global markets and we saw during the
pandemic that the UK was cut off from uh
skippol and Charles de Gaulle and
Frankfurt three times now if our
exporting strategy depended on flying
through those markets that would be a
disastrous strategy we need to have a
leading Global Hub here in the UK and
what we saw during the pandemic was just
how important cargo was with uh with
long-haul planes coming into Heathrow
bringing in PPE but we also saw how uh
spare capacity that briefly occurred at
Heathrow allowed more Regional flights
the more long-haul markets such as India
which we are poorly served to at the
moment and that shows the opportunity of
expanding he drove connecting all of
Britain to all the growing markets of
the world and that's what we should
deliver over the next decade or so so
beautiful staff have been taking
industrial action this winter do you
think those strikes could impact on
people some of the holiday plans
no not at all actually I have to give
credit to the Border Force Team who've
done a fantastic job in managing um
through the strikes and the service if
anything has been a report has been
better than it normally is and normally
it's pretty good uh here at Heathrow so
and they're great great credit and that
is our Focus as an airport we are a
consumer organization we want to get
people through the airports and on their
way as quickly as possible but the
Border in particular is the first front
door to the countries the first thing
that people see when they arrive here so
it's so important that people have a
good impression of the UK and even just
just the fact that you can uh passengers
from 40 countries can use the e-gate to
Heathrow that's a massive advantage that
the UK has and it's something we want to
build on to make the UK the most
attractive place to do business